[Musique]
salut les chicos chicas on se retrouve
aujourd'hui pour une vidéo de type
qualitative encore un bon plat jason
chaîne youtube ah oui alors c'est pas du
tout l'intro de cette personne par
contre vous le connaissez peut-être si
vous suivez sa chaîne voici vintage
strain je pousse vois pas ce que jésus
reviens très mal prononcé d'une gorge
vintage crainte c'est parfait ok on
t'appelle vigne quand même dingue on
m'appelle vinocamp mais tu sais que
beaucoup de gens me poser les questions
et beaucoup me disent est ce que vite et
c'est un vrai prénom est en fait
forcément non sedin toi mais en fait
j'avais le choix entre plusieurs pseudos
soit c'était un tout pour faciliter la
mémoire soit livinec ce soir ils
n'étaient pas ou quoi c'est donc j'ai
choisi vintage par souci d'esthétique
tard en fait si tu as tes appels
vinaigre crâne
tu vas être sur un moment donné comme a
fait youtube sous quand on fait plein 2
de changer de nom de chaîne un jour
c'est très relou quoi donc il faut bien
choisir et c'est une chaîne j'ai choisi
un ménage du mal comme ça c'est très
clair
alors confidence pour confidence ouais
moi ma chaîne s'appelle fabien olicard
et je ne l'appelle pas fabien si merde
mais par contre pour au lit car je
m'appelle aussi au lit car en fait du
coup j'avais pas du tout d'imagination
bref hockey aujourd'hui une petite zbox
une ouverture de boîtes basse caste est
évidemment et tu m'a confié hors caméra
ça fait très mireille dumas team a
confié aux caméras que tu avais les
larmes même temps qu'un enfant souviens
tu m'a confié que le tournage j'avais
trophée des casseurs
mélangeant les avait fait je crois que
le seul casse tête que j'ai fait c'est
celui dont nous faisons john que bon ça
va changer de ce dont tu as l'habitude
vinyl à une chaîne alors j'ai des gars
de parcours mais c'est peut-être
limitant ce jeudi je sais pas parcours
ou stop lifestyle toi ça fait des apéros
lifestyle dans ce temps sur des toits
non joué un lien dans la description
vers sa chaîne il fait principalement du
parcours en tout cas c'est comme ça que
je t'ai connu et un jour j'aurai droit à
une initiation sur des chaînes j'espère
mais totalement inquiète pas
là où j'ai pas été bon c'est vrai ça a
dû le faire quand il faisait beau ce que
j'ai en fait nan mais raison de plus
c'est un challenge
on va faire ça quand il fera froid il
neigera qu il vantera t'inquiète pas tu
auras toutes les conditions réunies on
va sortir du bureau c'est un challenge
et déjà je suis toujours là on me voit
toujours ici bienvenue dans le mien il
faut l'ouvrir
je te laisse donc voici la zbox pour
l'instant je te laisse la manipuler
voici les conseils que je donne moi
quand un casse tête pour la première
fois ces deux exactement faire ce que tu
fais le phase d'exploration pour voir ce
qu'il y à ce que sait comment ça marche
et comment on pourrait lui ouvrir les
boîtes en général elle s'ouvre avec
quelques mouvements et assez peu de
mouvements d'expérience sur la chaîne on
l'a vu d'même sur la weinstein box qui
était un peu décevante il suffisait de
faire une chose pour qu'elle s'ouvre
mais cette chose était très dur à
trouver elle n'était pas naturel quoi tu
vois d'accord je donc là il faut
forcément trouver une deux trois quatre
choses j'en sais rien qui vont permettre
de la développement et ce cas c'est toi
tu l'a jamais fait cela non non d'accord
king découvrant son ok très bien
il ya plusieurs petits trucs qui bougent
ainsi qu'un un truc qui tourne là il ya
comme un gros disque à l'intérieur
exactement bon enfant quelque chose du
genre
l'étoile je sais que dans tes vidéos tu
dis qu'il faut pas forcer certains cas
mais alors je disais ça je ne crie plus
à faire le poids jeudi plus parce que je
crois trois ans tout sur laquelle est en
fait à un moment donné il fallait forcer
il ya celle qu'on a fait avec loïc tu te
soumets à loïc
oui car ce bilan de ta venue voir trois
temps il fallait juste forcé c'était le
seul secret de la boîte line steinbock
soit les lui donner un gros coup la
pandora box et un moment donné il
fallait appuyer hyper fort sur un plan
pour débloquer un aimant donc les boîtes
à lettres dans le je m'en méfie exact ok
partons sur ce principe
alors ok donc il ya quand même les
pignons sur les côtés là qu'ils ont
l'air de bouli principal et pignons mais
c'est d'une soixante de type boisé de
déboiser qualitative donc exactement les
boiseries qualitative exactement et à
part ça il ya rien qui a l'air de bouger
mais je pense que c'est des trucs à
faire glisser en douce ton avis d'expert
me faire mon avis déjà les vices que je
ne tiens plus content parce que souvent
quand tu ouvres les boîtes qui voit que
la vie celle tenez rien c'est juste
portent leur genre donc effectivement
sur chaque face il ya toujours deux
têtes tous y ont saisi soir c'est le
sait le nom latin de 2 mais en fait je
crois qu'ils ont tous décroché aux
ravens a donc en fait jacques rogge
qu'il arrive comme son âme ou recto
comme ça ils pourront pas ne pouvons pas
éteindre des même si ça gigote un peu je
crois pas trop
si jamais ça c'est quoi c'est tout on ne
sait pas ce que c'est une vérité molette
mes genoux quoi on peut pas les
consommateurs à temps donc là on voit
qu'il ya un disque de métal qui se
baladent de ce côté là je sais pas si
vous voyez bien la campe au dessus nous
mais on voit que sa part à gauche ou à
droite simon commandes penche et au
dessus on a aussi comme je sais pas si
un disque au final mais en tout cas
c'est une pièce de métal perd c est
pareil ça tourne autour du truc
une petite forme soit sur you tube de
métal je pense qu'il faut le tourner de
façon ça va avec un système sera oui ou
alors cousin briques quelque chose de
pousser empêche l'ouverture
actuellement je vais mettre mon passé
vos trucs que je déconseille avant et
maintenant je me rasais pour les boîtes
à savoir essayer de forcer un autre
apple alors voilà c'est ça bouge et où
les vrais fans
elle attend regarde comme bouge lui
on voit que ça c'est appris en fait moi
ménages avaient découlé complète à
valensole d'accord là je force à mort et
je peux hockey et je peux pas plus donc
en fait qu'un regarde la tente du truc
c'est c1 comme s'il y avait eu et un
autre où je pense chaleur mais là tu as
à pied dessus ou pas j'appuie il par
lequel je force létale heures je devais
avoir les doigts sur le même parti mais
là du coup ok donc il ya quelque chose
qui bloque
a priori je pense que ce sont les
disques bravo sherlock abonnez vous en
fonction du d'orientation et de wen mira
d'une manière ou d'une autre sont les
disques qui qui qui bloque ça c'est sûr
si je fais ça je me retiens c'est qu'on
doit juste pour voir tous par agrément
tâter tâter mon ami tu t'es mon bon ami
titre référence à la vidéo précédent
vous pouvez voir ici
eh ben dis donc c'est pas facile cette
heure c'est à dire cette merde je pars
tu regardes ça juste moi je suis en
train dé mettre mal à l'aise pendant que
tu cherches d'accord bataille pour
gagner raison avec ton regard perçant
j'ai activé la roue est bien placé pour
voir ce qu'ils font ah ouais d'accord
lui avons la vidéo super ok ok bon cela
moi je galère ça merde je sais pas s'il
ya beaucoup de volume pour entrer des
choses on ne sait rien c'est très cool
je vous mets devient de la boîte dans la
description comme d'hab ça ça m'intrigue
ce disque là ce disque un peu que 26,6
un aimant dans un coin
se voit il ya des aimants ici juste
essayé de santé pour voir change quelque
chose
405 à oued accord non c'est 5 fallait
juste le centre et médard et les limites
je suis dégoûté voix quand ça se passe
comme ça c'est une âme et regarde
regarde profite en fait celui du dessus
aussi ses centres et je pense que les
deux doivent être centrés pour que ça
s'ouvre et que moi j'ai essayé de
centrer lui en donnant des petites
secousses
et du coup c'est à centre est aussi
celui qui la regarde ah oui d'accord et
je qui pense qu'en fait la vraie méthode
pour résoudre ça doit être de se garer à
centrer les 2 en même temps et que moi
ça s'est fait un peu par hasard leur
appartement ce n'est ce pas de danse là
c'est bien un disque de métal aussi il
celui qui perçait tu en voilà
j'ai donc si il déborde away regarde en
taxi le disque déborde s'il n'est pas
centré à wil rentrer là dedans et sa
force et celui du bas appareil le on le
voit lâche si vous voyez bien les ja il
ya une fente aussi ici et ça c'est de
disques qui a ici un peu plus en bas qui
doit rentrer dedans
ouais donc deux doivent être sans fait
on va vite être mais c'est intéressant
de savoir que pour tous les trucs là il
était inutile veille complètement fake
lévis les machins parce qu'en fait au
final c'est assez ingénieux par contre
c'est à dire qu'il ya tous les creux et
toutes les plaques ont été découpés
vraiment mm pour te faire chier
très clairement il faut te sort ultra
centre et [ __ ] j'ai eu un vrai génie
vol et après il ya eu ces deux gros
aimant qui retiennent danse en
martinique
ce qui veut dire d'ailleurs ce même pour
l'euro mais un juge et un petit peu
galère c'est ce que voilà il faut pas
écouter le principe d'un casse tête
c'est d'être défait des trophées donc je
te laisse les leur faire comme dans
l'autre sens vim
on va voir ça j'espère que ça ne va
aller je n'aime pas [ __ ] c'était un
acteur majeur parce que voilà ça c'est
le mec le l'homme le plus blessé au
monde fait part ça la caméra voilà quand
tu fais 10 par 181 toujours un peu bad
as que ce que tu as des mares partout
merci quoi mes marques c'est que j'ai
deux langues sur les doigts voilà j'ai
mon mark kirk a fui a pas la même ville
alors est inquiète alors déjà je sais
même pas leur place et attend aussi il
ya des trucs sur les côtés de la cochlée
kaunas
il est maintenant faut bien en fait là
il a fallu techniques bio liga ah oui
d'accord ok et c'est bien du tout aussi
du coup notre voie la joliesse battre
écoulement la crac assez vite je me suis
un peu de son niveau de difficulté on
vous mettra si je retrouve mes très très
chouette mais en vrai partage la mer
sont carrément intéressant c'est marrant
parce que quand on le manipule pas
forcément on est un peu penchée sur le
côté à chaque fois et ça ça vient par
exemple et de peut-être complètement
comme ça quoi en plus moi c'était un
test vraiment deux fils et quand ça va
trop vite j'ai toujours une déception
comme tout le monde tu me dire ah ouais
non mais non c'est pas un titre un
descriptif la description de films en
vrai je commence à voir des propositions
personne qui vous propose de créer mon
casse tête
et pour l'instant je réponds que non je
crois pas avoir l'ingéniosité pour créer
un casse-tête jeux pas trop mauvais pour
les résoudre
mais pour les créer faut vraiment penser
à tout ça tu vois il faut savoir ce qui
s'est déjà fait on ne veux pas tu vois
ça j'ai jamais vu un casse tête qui mena
qui fonctionnait sur la wii système là
je me dis aussi fallait avoir la
perversité d'inventer sa et tu sais en
fait ça ça me fait penser vraiment un
truc qui n'a aucun rapport
à savoir que je suis à lyon en spectacle
cette semaine et à toulon la semaine
prochaine et pour toutes les villes vous
avez le lien dans la description tu te
poser la question
la zbox je vous la fais gagner sur
instagram vous avez le lien dans la
description et vous allez voir cette
photo qui apparaît là entre nous sur un
stade
vous y allez vous commentez et vous
mettez le hashtag pour essayer de gagner
cette z box maintenant je vous fait
gagner les casse tête parce que je sais
plus quoi en foot j'en ai beaucoup trop
dans la description vous trouverez
également un lien vers la chaîne de bine
bine textron exactement vous pouvez vous
abonner à lui en cliquant ici ou au
moins déjà allés découvrir ces vidéos
parce que c'est vraiment ouf et et puis
moi je vais m'y coller bientôt ça me fit
le 6ème et 5ème franchement le en fin
d'entraînement de parcours et
franchement que tu verras ça hyper fan
ça je te fais aucune confiance vous
pouvez vous abonner un mois en cliquant
ici
ça c'est la vidéo du casse-tête de la
semaine dernière qui a été clairement le
plus galère de cette chaîne à faire mais
vraiment très galère n'hésitez pas les
lois à très bientôt
ciao